Hallo ihr Lieben, heute gibt es mal wieder was Türkisches. So viele haben gefragt: Kiki, wann machst du mal wieder was Türkisches?
Heute ist es soweit, aber
Vorab: Ich muss sagen, ich weiß nicht, ob es das in anderen Ländern auch gibt - mit Sicherheit. Ich persönlich kenne es nur aus der türkischen Küche.
Wir machen nämlich Zucchinipuffer 'Mücver' heißt es auf türkisch oder 'Mücver'. Das ist immer so schwierig auszusprechen. Auf jeden Fall gibt's...
Ja, du weißt es besser - du Araber. So - ich zeig euch jetzt aber erstmal die Zutaten. Wir benötigen natürlich Zucchini außerdem Eier,
und Mehl, Salz und Pfeffer habe ich hier. Getrocknete Minze, edelsüßes Paprikapulver und Petersilie - und noch etwas Öl zum ausbacken.
Der Teig ist eigentlich super schnell hergestellt. Das einzige, was wir jetzt vorbereiten müssen die Zucchini. Hab' ich jetzt erstmal das vordere Stück abgemacht
und schäl' sie jetzt
Und als nächstes reiben wir sie fein. Das habe ich jetzt mit der ersten Zucchini schon gemacht und die zweite kommt jetzt hinterher.
Und das wäre erledigt und weil Zucchini von Natur aus sehr viel Wasser enthält und wir das im Teig einfach nicht
gebrauchen können, werden wir das jetzt auswringen. Das geht ganz gut mit den Händen. Ihr könnt aber auch ein Tuch
nehmen. Ich zeig euch mal, wie ich das mache. Ich nehm' immer so 'ne Handvoll,
dann wring' ich das hier aus.
Und schaut mal wie viel Wasser da rauskommt.
So - der Teil wäre erledigt und die Reste, die eigentlich gar keine Reste sind. Die könnt ihr jetzt weiterverarbeiten
zur Gemüsesuppe zum Beispiel, also nicht wegschmeißen. Ich geb's da ganz kurz an die Seite.
Und für den Teig geben wir jetzt alle restlichen Zutaten in die Schüssel, bis auf das Öl.
Ich habe den Teig jetzt mit den sauberen Händen verknetet. Hab' da jetzt auch
keine Handschuhe genommen. Handschuhe nehm' ich persönlich immer gerne, wenn ich Wunden an den Fingern hab' oder wenn das Fleisch ist oder
so ein richtig klebriger Teig, aber das habe ich jetzt so erledigt. Und ich hole jetzt ganz kurz meine Pfanne, und dann backen die aus.
Ihr habt nichts verpasst, keine Sorge, ich hab' die ersten nur schon mal -huch- nur schon mal ausgebacken.
So - und gemeinsam backen wir jetzt die nächsten. Ich hab natürlich das Öl schon in der Pfanne erhitzt.  Nehmt nicht die allerhöchste Stufe, aber geht schon
ein bisschen höher und jetzt nehm' ich mir zwei Esslöffel zu Hilfe und mach' dann immer so runde kleine Taler (da)raus.
Meine Zucchinipuffer sind fertig und sie brauchen in der Pfanne ungefähr eineinhalb Minuten pro Seite. Und weil ich wusste, dass die Frage
aufkommen wird, habe ich einen im Ofen ausprobiert, bei 200 Grad, zehn Minuten. Also es funktioniert
auch. Es ist aber bei Weitem nicht
so knusprig, als wenn man sie ausbrät. Also, das nur
so am Rande. Ich empfehle auf jeden Fall die Pfannenvariante mit Öl und ich mach' jetzt
noch einen Joghurtdip dazu. Das zeige ich euch. Ich hab' hier einfach nur Joghurt
1,5 prozentigen. Ihr könnt natürlich auch 3,5  oder 10 prozentigen nehmen. Ganz euch überlassen. Und ich 'pimp' das jetzt
noch auf mit Salz und Knoblauch. Und am Ende kommt dann noch ein bisschen getrocknete Minze drüber.
So, falls ihr jetzt auch richtig Lust habt auch die türkischen Zucchinipuffer, dann schaut unten in die Infobox. Da schreibe ich
euch wie immer die genauen Mengenangaben hin. Ansonsten gibt dem Video fleißig ein Däumchen nach oben.
Kommentiert was ihr als Nächstes sehen möchtet. Gerne auch wieder in die türkische Richtung. Da war nämlich die Nachfrage
immer ganz hoch. Kannst du mal türkische Gerichte zeigen. Mache ich wie immer von Herzen gerne. Also, eure Vorschläge gerne in die Kommentare
Ansonsten abonniert meinen Kanal kostenlos, wenn ihr es nicht schon längst getan habt und dann sehen wir uns auch beim nächsten Mal
auf Kiki's kitchen. Tschüss